[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi presento il beato è un concetto che
viene dal mondo della lubrificazione e
sta a indicare quello spazio
impercettibile che sta a separare due
oggetti che sono a contatto
sì perché in realtà quando due oggetti
sono a contatto e noi pensiamo che lo
siano in realtà non lo sono
esiste sempre una sottilissima membrana
anche dipende appunto la cui altezza
dipende dal materiale stesso che li
separa la prima volta che entrai in
contatto con il concetto di reato se
devo sui banchi di ingegneria
all'università di pisa che ero
ingegneria probabilmente levate dedotto
dalla scelta che faccio nelle immagini
in per le mie slide e di quella lezione
però non riuscì più a seguire nulla ero
totalmente immerso nel mio mondo non
riuscivo a non pensare alle complicate
alle conseguenze più concrete che questa
per me scoperta avrebbe avuto nella vita
banalmente che nell'abbraccio il gesto
più intimo che ci sia nella relazione
umana
in realtà non ci stavamo toccando
davvero c'era sempre una parte di noi la
parte più estesa che non era a contatto
questa forma irriducibile di separazione
ci rendeva in ultima istanza tutti
estremamente soli
fu quel giorno che scoprì di essere
condannato la sensibilità nel mio caso
questa condanna poi avrei scoperto
sarebbe stata ancora più grave perché
avrebbe preso poi la deriva della
sensibilità per la poesia non era però
la prima volta in assoluto che la
sensibilità si affacciava nella mia vita
la prima volta che successe lo fece
tramite la finestra della matematica
avevo più o meno questa età aveva appena
imparato a contare fino a mille cose di
cui ero già molto orgoglioso e un giorno
andai da mio padre gli disse papa ma
esattamente l'ultimo numero
mio padre rispose
non esiste un ultimo numero i numeri
sono infiniti sbam
quella notte non riusciva a prendere
sonno e se ci ripenso anche adesso se
ripenso all'ultimo numero se ripenso
all'ultimo decimali del pi greco
mi si apre dentro una vertigine la
stessa vertigine che avverto quando sono
più vulnerabile ed è in quei momenti di
vulnerabilità mi rendo conto che sono
più tendente a scrivere
tant'è che le cose che scrivono sono
spesso molto serene ma d'altronde come
diceva tenco se le cose che scrivo sono
tristi è perché quando sono felice
tendenzialmente esco
la poesia però diciamo non è
un'invenzione è qualcosa che esiste già
va solo estratta come michelangelo
faceva andando a liberare dal marmo in
eccesso le figure che già abitavano
quelle colonne
la poesia è qualcosa di innato in noi e
provo a dimostrarvelo sentire questa la
mia mano è vuota
nubi e sudori nel corpo onde del sangue
che gela per la paura respiro con il
vento argento tuoni negli occhi nella
mente c'è il mare
ecco questa poesia non è di alda merini
di eugenio montale è di wight new un
bambino cinese di 9 anni che ha fatto un
laboratorio di poesia con sandra lee via
candiani a milano come intuirete in
queste in queste parole non c'è
sofisticazione non c'è un gesto di
astuzia c'è semplicemente semplicemente
un urgenza una spontaneità lo stesso
candore di un bambino che di notte non
riesce a dormire perché pensa all ultimo
numero
come se ci pensate
di fatto il poeta il mestiere più facile
del mondo basta andare a capo ogni tot
parole non esiste un registro mondiale
dei poeti non esiste un'autorità che
dichiara qualcuno poeta poeta ci si
autodichiara ci si
auto diploma e se ci pensate
appunto non esiste un mestiere del tutto
al sicuro neanche dalla poesia c'è stato
solo un periodo in realtà in cui
esisteva un registro di poeti sul serio
in russia nella russia sovietica dove
appunto c'era qualcuno che veniva
stipendiato per tutti gli altri è un è
un gesto che in qualche modo è
spontaneo va va dichiarato non esiste
però appunto nessun mestiere che sia del
tutto al sicuro dalla poesia la sua luce
con pene tra ovunque
trafila qualsiasi attività umana
quotidiana anche il linguaggio tecnico
stesso gli acronimi che spesso possono
sembrare respingenti rispetto al mondo
della poesia possono essere la da una
fonte d'ispirazione
se ci pensate non scrivevano poesia ma
comunque poesia in prosa dostoevskij e
gaza che erano
esimi colleghi ingegneri vonnegut il
maestro americano del novecento ha
venduto per un lungo periodo della sua
vita automobili e kafka che dire di
kafka non avremmo avuto gregor samsa se
kafka non si fosse annoiato nel suo
piccolo cubicolo in un ufficio delle
assicurazioni generali a praga
ecco quando mi chiedo come spesso come
spesso succede cosa pensano gli altri di
noi di noi ingegneri gli altri nel senso
quelli che ingegneri non solo perché ho
scoperto poi strada facendo erano
esistevano anche delle persone che non
erano ingegneri e spesso non so cosa
rispondermi e un giorno trovai per caso
passeggiando per una città una risposta
su un muro che era questa gli ingegneri
sanno tutto
ma sanno solo quello
ecco in difesa degli ingegneri abbiamo
dovuto chiamare un fisico però che
fisico richard feynman premio nobel per
la fisica che nel suo celebre discorso
della rosa
disse a un suo amico che lo accusava un
suo amico poeta che lo accusava in
qualche modo di essere troppo troppo
freddo troppo razionale anche nel
descrivere la bellezza di un fiore egli
rispose così io vedo in un fiore molte
più cose di quante ne veda tu
posso immaginare le cellule le complesse
azioni che si svolgono al suo interno
non c'è soltanto bellezza a questa
dimensione alla dimensione di un
centimetro la bellezza anche alle
dimensioni inferiori
la struttura interna i processi il fatto
che i fiori e il colore stesso dei fiori
si siano evoluti per attirare gli
insetti ad impallinarlo tutto questo
aggiunge bellezza non capisco in che
modo possa sottrarre
ecco c'è un altro signore che questo con
la pipa che si risponde al nome di pablo
neruda che ha scritto una cosa in cui mi
ritrovo moltissimo visto che credo che
realtà ingegneri e poesia non siano mai
stati davvero distinti ma intimamente
connaturati e questo verso è un verso
che appunta molto in auge e che fa così
voglio fare con te quello che la
primavera fa qui ciliegi
bellissimo poeticissimo un po abusato
ecco però quello che voglio dirvi oggi è
che in realtà se ci pensate ogni scienza
ogni mestiere ha già avuto l'equivalente
di una primavera per i ciliegi einstein
ha portato in fisica quello che la
primavera fa con i ciliegi mander brott
ha rigirato la matematica facendola
sbocciare come la primavera fa coi
ciliegi
ecco esiste un comun denominatore tra
ingegneria e poesia e della ricerca
dell'efficacia per l'ingegneria e
utilizzare il minor numero di materie
prime per ottenere un risultato di
produzione di fatturato
sia e utilizzare il minor numero di
lemmi di parole per arrivare al cuore
della questione
mio amico caro poeta un giorno mi disse
fosse per me l'inchiostro sarebbe la
materia più cara del mondo
ecco la poesia e l'ingegneria si muovono
in maniera diversa per arrivare a questo
obiettivo l'ingegneria utilizza
principalmente il metodo deduttivo la
poesia principalmente scorciatoie quindi
epifanie folgorazioni però se ci pensate
il m'illumino d'immenso di ungaretti è
l'equivalente in fisica delle leggi
newtoniane alla stessa eleganza la
stessa bellezza di f uguale matera
ecco oggi sono consulente per start up e
aziende corporate principalmente nel
mondo dell'innovazione tra gli ingegneri
sono ancora visto come poeta tra i poeti
come l'ingegnere con un certo tipo di
discriminazione in entrambi i casi e
devo dire che questo mi ha creato un po
di imbarazzo specialmente all'inizio del
mio percorso sia nel mio percorso
professionale dove effettivamente
tendevo a nascondere un po i miei datori
di lavoro questa mia doppia vita e siano
in poi tre slam che sono queste gare di
poesia in contesti anticonvenzionali
quindi in bari in piazze dove ci si
espone al pubblico ludibrio
declamando i propri versi è appunto
facendoli giudicare a una platea che
spesso è abbastanza impietosa vi sono
poi reso conto in realtà che questo
imbarazzo era piuttosto immotivato e
anzi che questa poteva essere mio punto
di forza
in poesia mi permetteva di collocarmi in
un posto dove nessun altro aveva un
certo tipo di sensibilità un certo tipo
di competenze mentre sul lavoro mi
permetteva di non solo semplificare i
concetti ma fare una cosa che solo la
poesia fa così bene che è renderli
memorabili
ecco oggi quando lavoro sugli elevator
pitch che sono queste questi discorsi in
cui in nel tempo di una di una salita di
una corsa in ascensore bisogna
convincere un potenziale investitore a
finanziare la propria idea la propria
startup lavoro molto sulla parte di
navigazione sul rendere i concetti più
ispiranti più poetici qualche modo più
memorabili e non è un caso credo che il
minutaggio sia proprio lo stesso sia per
i pc che per il poetry slam intorno ai 3
minuti
ecco io leggo un po di stupore e un po
di come dire
scetticismo in alcuni di voi perché
capisco che ci sia qualcuno le dice sì
tutto bello tutto fighissimo
però io faccio il cassiere all esselunga
dove la trovo la poesia nel mio mestiere
è evidente che ci siano dei mestieri che
sono più poetici più tendenti alla
poesia
in italia in particolare le metafore e
allegorie poetiche sono sprecate nel
mondo della ristorazione ma anche la
botanica non esiste un poeta che non
possa essere almeno un po
giardiniere perché deve avere una certa
sensibilità del sapere riconoscere le
piante sappe di dare i giusti nomi però
vi invito a fare questo esercizio
provate per un attimo a pensare al
mestiere più noioso più irritante che vi
venga in mente nel xxi secolo
vi do qualche secondo per pensarci per
dirvi che in realtà noi questa domanda
ce la siamo già fatta
e quando dico noi intendo il collettivo
dei miti l'anti con cui da qualche anno
animiamo questo golfo che per noi ancora
il golfo dei poeti in con le nostre
attività appunto di poesia
noi ci siamo fatti questa domanda ci
siamo dati una risposta
ci è venuto in mente a tutti lo stesso
mestiere quasi all'unanimità
il mestiere è l'operatore del call
center
se ci pensate l'operatore del call
center mette d'accordo tutti è il
mestiere più democratico del mondo in
questo senso lo odia chi lo fa lo odia
chi nel ricevere chiamate
ecco ci siamo chiesti c'è una maniera di
riscattare questo mestiere e ne è venuto
fuori questo
io no sono filippo dei miti l'anti salve
io mi chiamo andrea fabiani
sono andrea bonomi ma mi chiamo alfonso
p al giorno sono francesco terzago
chiamo la spezia per conto dei miti
l'anti che è un collettivo poetico e
stiamo conducendo un un esperimento
volevo chiederle se posso occupare le
trenta secondi tra leggerne una coesione
a legna nel camino nel quale stanno
brano
tempo dice la scienza no detto devo
scegliere se essere scortese per la
guardia dopotutto lavorando a di
pazienza non posso guardando accettando
la rabbia facciamo dominata in cose che
sono più alcuno da numeriche che dopo il
grazie di tutte le intelligenze quella
emotiva che connette i pensieri fonda la
gentilezza
di tutte le leggi fisiche l'attrito che
abilita la passeggiata in giro alle 6
del mattino
ci sono solamente i mezzi pubblici
e i mezzi scemi
ma guardati i piedi le ruote non ce l'ha
questo era primo revit una io quella
seguente
cioè noi eravamo detti fermi in
tangenziale
per fare un nome
servono
almeno due persone
per disfarlo basta è il silenzio di
una sola
e bella complimenti
perché ci sono altre
di non vivere sangue il mio problema era
anche lui rimase altri
ecco questa iniziativa ha avuto nel
piccolo mondo di nika dalla poesia un
certo successo ed è stata poi copiata
anche da altri collettivi una cosa di
cui siamo sinceramente anche molto
contenti e orgogliosi
anzi il mio invito di oggi è questo
fatelo anche voi questa sera quando
tornate a casa
prendete un elenco telefonico iniziato a
chiamare dei numeri a caso per la gioia
delle poesie
l'obiettivo è quello di insinuare il
dubbio cioè che la prossima volta che
qualcuno di voi riceve una chiamata da
un numero sconosciuto non abbia paura di
rispondere perché tema che magari
qualcuno gli voglia vendere un
abbonamento telefonico un frigorifero ma
realtà che speri che qualcuno gli stia
per fare un gesto di gentilezza che di
voglia regalare un momento di poesia
guardate
se chiedete a qualcuno qual è il suo
poeta preferito fatelo come esperimento
tutti vi risponderanno delle persone
morte ma la poesia è una cosa viva ma
solo riconosciuta estrapolata da quello
che facciamo nelle nostre attività
quotidiane
sta a noi essere ambasciatori nel nostro
piccolo mondo nel nostro mestiere per
farlo in qualche modo sbocciare per
farlo diventare un'opera d'arte per
farlo diventare memorabile
per cui inventatevi delle metafore
migliori lasciatevi sorprendere dalla
vostra attività quotidiana non so che
può sembrare una maratona stancante
vista da qui ma l'alta non è una
maratona è una staffetta una staffetta
collettiva in cui ognuno di noi deve
passare il testimone al vicino di
scrivania vicino del mestiere continuo
ecco il mio impegno e la mia sfida
quotidiana è quella di trasformare
e anche l'ultimo mestiere in ordine
cronologico che sono stato chiamato a
fare e che da quel poco che ho capito è
anche per distacco il più difficile di
tutti che è quello di padre
e il mio obiettivo è quello di
trasmettere a mia figlia olivia la
l'importanza e la capacità di conservare
lo stupore che oggi lei applica al mondo
perché guardate il senso del nostro
passaggio su questo pianeta
il nostro cervello più ingegneristico
più razionale tende a collocarlo sempre
nel conforto dei numeri quindi quanta
nostro fatturato quanto al nostro
stipendio quanti follower abbiamo ma il
senso risiede in quello che riusciamo a
costruire in realtà intorno a noi
con o senza un budget con o senza un
audience ad applaudirci ed è la nostra
infinita capacità di generare bellezza
come ogni padre ho passato le prime
notti diciamo i primi anni della vita di
mia figlia a sperare che avesse un sonno
regolare
le uniche notti insonni che le auguro
sono quelle in cui si perderà nella
meraviglia della conoscenza andate e
siate memorabili
[Applauso]